I am black against none light Lord and
welcome to this video okay my first two
moves are clear the fianchetto week is
in effect I only hope someone is not
going one age for that would make one g6
look really silly okay it didn't happen
so yeah we got a proper modern defense
okay let's see what are you going okay
it's playing the this quiet set up with
Knight f3 and h3 yeah that's very
restrained but ok it's very solid of
course and 83 yeah that is more passive
than solid ok let's see what what we get
III and 83 has really really quiet quiet
plane um yo what do we do Knight to f6
source do we start let's start with that
maybe get a quick c5n let's do c5 I
don't see a big problem with it no one
real funny point about this is they have
a look at that and what I'm getting now
it's like a great disown you know it's
it's it's a great act of Sicilian and
whites setup is quite strange with h3a
three and yeah nothing's nothing's right
basically in white set up that's really
nice this position so let's see I can
play how can I do that ee 5 and d5 would
be quite nice I can check be five maybe
if I've put should be 3d 5 85 95 oh
sorry 85 95
95 bishop d5 Bishop b5 we should have
three Bishop d7 huh that's not good okay
I can prepare that with rookie ate the
whole thing maybe let's prepared with
rupee aid it is generally useful anyways
okay he's not reacting to it at all and
here we go now we cannot take even
because of before losing a piece that
was the idea why not before winning a
piece I don't get it Yvonne now it just
winds a piece it was the idea of root
yet it was not just a wedding with
strange
we're after d5 it was a bit
uncomfortable for white already but it
didn't yet needed to give me a whole
piece him it was a real excellent
opening result of the modern quite
resigned that there's really an
advantage of this opening if white is
playing somewhat meek yeah like this
with h 3 and a 3 yeah h3 is not so bad
it often is quite useful in connection
with like Bishop e3 so that Knight f6
Jeff is not hitting with a 3 is really
really on there on the slow each side
and yeah I don't know probably you want
to not spend the temple with that but
have a look at this I'm getting a
Sicilian now basically kind of it's kind
of a dragon almost yeah but what has why
done bishop is strange on d4 and he has
played those two very slow moves and now
well he fell before it's not hanging yet
but he felt he had to to do something
about it and well this is already
looking very nice I have many many good
options I wanted to do this but as I
said this is not yet working s at the
end he can check here and that's a bit
bad yes i can i can take here he takes
him and it's just a born down so i went
rook e8 to prepare that and i think he
has to react somehow to that not quite
sure with what exactly but rookie one
didn't didn't do the job this is now
already tricky I'm threatening to win
here peace and to peace with d 4 i'm
taking it can also not to so what is his
move yeah probably has to move the
bishop and act like this then i have
defied list which is yeah brilliant
brilliant opening result for black yeah
I've got a space advantage and
everything's great here that looks like
yeah fantastic but really great yeah but
well he blundered this piece which is
which put in a quick son end to the game
um I'm not sure if you if you really
want to go on if you want to go h3 here
in response to a six I think it's
actually not a bad idea to go away for
just just stop just stop the b5 IDM
beehive is a is a move that is some yeah
its ambitious and quite often actually
good for black as long as the queenside
weaknesses cannot be exploited quickly
and a force a way to stop b5 sometimes
sometimes if we go back it's about move
orders here but let's say here here a
six is not good or anything okay you can
play that but c4 is coming and then be
five is completely impossible or there
are also sometimes ideas like let's say
here and now be five can be answered
with a four there's no knight on c3 that
can be attacked but whenever there is a
knight on c3 b5 gains billion strength
and I think you really should consider
to go be five at go to Goa form
something like that it's also
interesting just going for development
because it's not clear this is actually
possible yeah this is attacking upon and
I have nothing developed as black so I
might have to to continue like that and
yeah well you know maybe e5 on some some
other idea just play a bit more dynamic
than dynamically then with a three okay
well thanks for watching